continue place à notre grand débat on
s'arrête à nouveau ce soir sur l'horreur
des féminicides les défaillances dans lé
drame de mérignac et dayan je ne font
aucun doute un nouveau rapport accablant
a été remis hier soir aux autorités
résultat le gouvernement annonce de
nouvelles mesures bracelet téléphone
expertise renforcée ce que cette fois
les moyens sont suffisants barbe ouvrir
le débat avec nos invités dans un
instant d'abord les explications de
pierre henry l 2 rebonds chahinez 31 ans
et mère de trois enfants est morte
brûlée vive par son mari à mérignac le 5
mai dernier un rapport d' enquête a été
demandée par le gouvernement qui
pointent plusieurs failles dans le suivi
du mari violent multirécidiviste il
révèle un manque de communication entre
la police et la justice
l'absence de protection de la victime
avant la libération de son conjoint
violent et d' expertise avant un
aménagement de peine
hier soir le premier ministre a reçu le
garde des sceaux ainsi que gérald
darmanin marlène schiappa elisabeth
moreno dans un communiqué le
gouvernement annonce de nouvelles
mesures pour renforcer la protection des
victimes
une mise à disposition de 3000 téléphone
grave danger d'ici 2022
une fusion des fichiers entre la police
et la justice un renforcement du
contrôle de détention et d'acquisition
d'armes à feu un fichier pour recenser
les auteurs de violence et un plan de
renforcement du recours au bracelet anti
rapprochement
pour la présidente de la délégation des
droits des femmes au sénat c'est une
première avancée
on peut aller plus loin nous avons
adopté de nombreuses loi depuis quelques
années sur ces la grande cause du
quinquennat désormais ces lois elles
doivent être appliquées
ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui donc il
ya un vrai souci de l'application de la
loi à tous les niveaux par année deux
cent mille femmes subissent des
violences en 2010 946 féminicide ont été
recensés soit 56 meurtres de plus qu'en
2020 selon le collectif féminicide par
compagnon ou ex
cinquante et une femme sont mortes
depuis le début de l'année avec nous ce
soir pour le grand débat del pozo et
royaux bienvenue vous êtes avocate au
barreau de paris et porte parole de la
fondation des femmes fassent avoue
isabelle rome bienvenue à wigan haute
fonctionnaire au ministère de la justice
en charge de l'égalité femmes hommes
vous êtes fondatrice de l'association
femmes de liberté et co auteur de
l'emprise et les violences au sein du
couple avec nous également mais est
distant laurence garnier bienvenue
sénatrice l air de loire atlantique
membre de la commission des affaires
sociales vous êtes à l'origine
d'interpel réseau de femmes de droite et
du centre de loire-atlantique et vous
soutenez l'association raisonnante de
djata enjoy qu'on connaît bien puisqu'on
l'a reçue dans dialogue citoyen ici sur
public sénat françoise brié bienvenue à
vous également
vous êtes directrice générale de la
fédération nationale solidarité femmes
et ancien membre du haut conseil à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
merci à toutes les quatre d'être avec
nous zoé royaux je voudrais d'abord vous
entendre sur les mesures annoncées par
les gouvernements genre cite trois bris
avant parce qu'elles sont majeurs enfin
je crois un fichier des auteurs de
violences conjugales un plan de
renforcement du recours au bracelet anti
rapprochement et 3000 téléphone grave
danger d'ici à 2022 est ce que vous
diriez cette fois ça y est on y met les
moyens
non enfin je dirais passage je dirais
que c'est formidable d'avoir des actions
qui visent à renforcer la lutte contre
les violences sexuelles et sexistes
mais je dirais que de quels moyens par
le temps faim la mission ne parle pas du
budget il ya aucun moment où est abordé
la question de l'argent on nous dit plus
de moyens plus de téléphone mais quid
des moyens financiers donc le budget
n'ait pas augmenté donc comment fait-on
avec les mêmes montants
donc pour vous c'est pas du tout
suffisant les six mesures annoncées non
pour moi c'est pas c'est pas non c'est
pas suffisant
isabelle rome oui les mesures annoncées
en fait s'inscrivent déjà dans une
logique qui avait été amorcée lors du
grenelle des violences conjugales un qui
avait organisé par le gouvernement entre
septembre et novembre 2019
puisque ensuite il y avait déjà eu une
première loi qui avait permis à la fois
le déploiement du bassin ti
rapprochement le renforcement de l'usagé
du téléphone grave danger et ça arrive
après toute une batterie donc là on voit
bien qu'on est dans 700 ce renforcement
de ces mesures qui d'ailleurs sont en
train de monter en puissance par exemple
le téléphone grave danger début 2019 en
avait trois cents femmes protéger
aujourd'hui d'un attrait s'envoyer est
là
eh bien ça veut dire que ce dispositif
est efficace
il ya eu par exemple il intervention en
2020 donc ça veut dire mille agression
éviter est donc cet objectif d'aller
jusqu'à 3000 évidemment que ce que ça
peut servir
et pour le brest anti rapprochement il
ya eu les 1000 dispositif lancé donc en
septembre 2019 par le garde des sceaux
des directives qu'il a prises l'a
récemment et on voit là en un mois un
doublement des deux des décisions donkey
qui octroie justement ce bracelet
rapprochement donc je pense que dans les
mois qui vont venir on devrait assister
vraiment une montée en puissance de ce
solo et royaux je vois que vous avez
envie de réagir avant de donner la
parole à noter parce que j'aimerais
savoir quelles sont les nouvelles
mesures en réalité on dit toujours un
peu la même chose c'est à dire que la la
mission nous dit deux objectifs assurer
la protection des victimes et renforcer
le suivi des auteurs très bien comment
en communiquant plus une politique de
communication de politique transversale
pour tous les acteurs et les actrices de
la chaîne judiciaire formidable idée
bonne mais ce que les nouvelles non elle
est pas nouvelle en fait elles datent
d'une circulaire de 2014 vous savez très
bien qui déjà prévoyait qu'ils puissent
avoir un référent procureur en matière
de violence conjugale dans chaque parc
et de france ce n'est pas le cas parce
que non pas en fait pas dans tous les
parcs france j'ai vu quand on l'a évalué
la france avec le conseil de l'europe ce
n'est pas le cas dans tous les parcs à
tous en selle
là chaque parquet peut vous donner sans
référent c'est formidable
alors et par ailleurs on nous dit aussi
est effectivement alors pour la la
communication pardon j'ai je perdais le
fil la loi post grenelle dont vous
parliez du 28 décembre 2012 prévoyait
déjà une politique de communication
transversale entre tous les acteurs de
la chaîne judiciaire
donc ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et
c'est précisément pour ça qu'on a encore
51 féminicide alors françoise brié je
pense que c'est une étape qui avancent
aussi vers l'augmentation des téléphones
grave danger la mise en place des bars
maintenant la question des structures
spécialisées des pôles spécialisés
et à tous les niveaux c'est vrai que si
on veut avoir des personnes présentes 24
heures sur 24 dans les services de
police et de gendarmerie à voir ces
référents effectivement dans tous les
tribunaux
il faut les renforcer en tous les cas il
faut donner des moyens effectivement
dans toute la chaîne pour que les
articulations se fasse c'est vrai par
exemple sur les suivis des auteurs de
violences nous avions demandé au moment
du grenelle que les victimes soient
alertés un moment de la sortie
d'incarcération lorsqu'il y avait une
décision judiciaire lorsqu'il y avait un
non-respect des mesures judiciaires par
l'eau par l'agresseur donc ça aussi
c'est important de pouvoir suivre ces
mesures et faire en sorte aussi que ça
se met vraiment en place lorraine
extrêmement bon
nous demandons effectivement a sonné un
renforcement des structures spécialisées
ou dépôts spécialisée tout au long du
parcours des femmes pour que ligne et
pas de faille finalement dans les
informations dans la continuité des
échanges et que toutes les femmes
puissent aussi s'appuyer sur ces
référents au moment où elles sont en
danger
laurence garnier comment avez vous perçu
cette annonce de six nouvelles mesures
hier soir ce qui est certain c'est que
les mesures elles vont dans le bon sens
une fois qu'on a annoncé ces mesures je
concept qu'il n'y a ni les moyens
financiers
en face ça coûte de l'argent de les
appliquer ni le déploiement effectif de
ces bonnes intentions que je crois
chacun salue mais dans les faits je
rejoins ce que disais à l'instant au zoo
a rien de nouveau sous le soleil ces
annonces elles sont en fait et c'est
terrible le constat d'échec des mesures
précédentes et il s'agit de mettre en
place un certain nombre de dispositifs
qui sont déjà inscrits dans la loi et
qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas appliqués
ont comparé des bracelets
anti-rapprochement je crois que la loi
prévoyait d'en mettre à disposition 1000
pour les sommes concernées par ces
violences conjugales acheteurs de ces
violences conjugales et qu'il y en a
aujourd'hui 78 en circulation donc
les annonces elles mêmes elles vont dans
le bon sens ce qui est à craindre c'est
qu'elle dresse au stade d'annonce et que
pendant ce temps là des femmes
continuent à mourir comme on le voit
tragiquement et comme on l'a encore vu
ces derniers jours
si on reste sur l'exemple des bracelets
anti-rapprochement et des téléphones
grave danger isabelle rome j'entendais
ce matin l'avocate spécialisée isabelle
steyer que vous connaissez probablement
sur france info elle nous disait il ya
220 mille plaintes pour des faits de
violences conjugales
on se retrouve aujourd'hui avec 4000
téléphone grand danger ce n'est rien par
rapport aux plaintes si on estime qu'il
y à 10% de femmes en situation de grave
danger il nous faudrait 22000 bracelet
22000 téléphone nous sommes loin du
compte que répondre à certain je pense
que les projections sont toujours bien
sur le papier et dans les discours voilà
moi je suis avant tout une juge avant
d'être haute fonctionnaire les jeux
chette ce jeu c'est que chaque situation
est différente et toute situation ne
nécessite pas forcément un bras sentiers
rapprochement c'est à dire que vous avez
une gradation dans les mesures qui
peuvent être prononcées on peut avoir
par exemple un un contrôle judiciaire
avec une interdiction d'entrer en
contact on peut voir une mesure d'
ordonnance de protection et d'ailleurs
qui a été beaucoup améliorée par la loi
du toujours cette fois de décembre 2019
avec un délai de 6 jours qui est
maintenant je veux dire tous les
tribunaux font cet effort on suit
d'ailleurs et j'ai bien entendu ce que
disait madame la sénatrice les lois qui
ont été votées nous les accompagnons
c'est ce que nous faisons depuis depuis
le vote de ces deux lois qu'il s'agisse
de l' ordonnance de protection donc avec
un comité de l' ordonnance de protection
qu'avec des remontées très fréquent des
tribunaux pour voir justement comment ça
marche une circulaire envoyée se déjuger
les dépêches adressée par le garde des
sceaux puis un travail en profondeur
c'est à dire que on regarde ce qui se
passe donc en fait les lois elles sont
accompagnées
s'agissant de la loi du 30 juillet 2020
qui notamment a permis aux médecins et
aux soignants de signaler des faits de
violence conjugale sans l'accord de la
victime parce que il faut signaler tout
aussi si on veut éviter le pire il faut
aussi signaler tôt et bien cette loi
nous l'accompagnons aussi avec les
médecins avec la haute autorité de santé
voilà nous avons fait un vade-mecum des
protocoles locaux sont signés voilà
alors évidemment ce ne sont pas des
choses très spectaculaire moi j'évite le
plus possible d'être dans les batailles
de chiffres enfin voilà parce que
effectivement on peut en donner enfin je
veux dire mais on peut voyez quand je
vous dis par exemple 300 femmes protège
et récents aujourd'hui les voilà moi
même je me situe là dedans mais en fait
le travail en profondeur il est quand
même fait il est je pense que ce qui est
important peut-être aussi de d'indiquer
c'est que il ya une vieille une forte
volonté gouvernementale
il ya la volonté pour lima la saison
au moment du grenelle des efforts voilà
les lois les mesures qui vont avec les
mille les 1000 bracelets sont
disponibles ils sont disponibles
c'est juste que c'est la montée en
puissance de la mise en oeuvre du
dispositif qui est le fait c'est leur
seul moyen très lentement
en fait si vous voulez on a quand même
passé trois marchés publics en un an fin
voyez enfin il faut aussi expliquer les
choses de manière lucide c'est à dire
que quand on regarde les choses de
l'extérieur tout paraît effectivement
extrêmement lent mais si on décompose le
fonds pour les femmes en fait un lent
pour ces belles âmes qui sont maîtrisés
souhaita fallon mais moi aussi je pense
à elle je suis ta vie voilà et si on
fait tout ça c'est bien pour justement
pour éviter tous et tous ces faits mais
d'ici d'éminemment oui merci
contrairement à ce que vous dites c'est
pas des batailles de chiffres pour
pouvoir lutter contre un phénomène tel
que les violences conjugales il faut
d'abord pouvoir le quantifier comprendre
de quoi on parle là en mesure au nombre
de femmes mortes
c'est un indicateur mais c'est pas
suffisant par exemple en espagne vous
savez ils ont une plateforme qui
s'appelle view gènes qui recense tous
les éléments d'information c'est à dire
le nombre de plaintes déposées
l'issue la condamnation la teneur de la
condamnation le nombre de récidives à ce
que le récidiviste était suivi
psychologiquement ou pas est ce que ça
fonctionne
le nombre de bracelets
anti-rapprochement de téléphone grave
danger dans nos protections bref pour
pouvoir comprendre parce que là on fait
des missions sur chaque féminicide et
puis on regarde ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné mais on le sait ce qui n'a
pas fonctionné
mais si on prend du recul et qu'on a on
envisage de phénomène dans son ensemble
on peut apporter une réponse qui est
globale la réponse elle peut pas
uniquement judiciaire et policière faut
qu'elles soient aussi sociale et
éducative répression auprès protection
c'est bien les préventions c'est
important aussi
donc moi je pense qu'au contraire les
chiffres ont leur importance parce
qu'ils sont objectifs et qu il faut
qu'on puisse s'y mesurer et ensuite
avoir un budget qui répondent à cette
priorité politique doivent être la lutte
contre les violences sexuelles et
sexistes
puisque vous prenez le cas de l'espagne
je comptais en parler plus tard mais je
voudrais qu'on le reprenne lentement
parce qu'ils aient repris assez
régulièrement cet exemple de l'espagne
soutient quelques jours libération a
publié un article titré titré ainsi 5
féminicide en une semaine l'espagne
s'alarme face à un fléau machiste je
fermais guimet et cité les propos de la
présidente de l'observatoire contre la
violence domestique et de jenson
hypothèse la recrudescence des
féminicides peut être lié
récente levée de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire il ya aussi cette question du
contexte et elle disait ceci le retour à
la normalité peut augmenter la peur de
l'agresseur de perdre le contrôle sur
ses victimes
donc ça veut dire que même dans un pays
qui a pris conscience du problème qu'il
a pris à bras le corps depuis bien bien
plus longtemps que nous le problème est
en train de ressurgir et il semblerait
qu'on n'y arrive pas françoise brié vous
l'aviez vu cette information est ce que
ça vous pose question puisqu'on prend
tout le temps l'espagne comme exemple je
pense que toute façon la période de
pandémie est un peu particulière c'est
vrai qu'on a vu aussi en france une
période de confinement tous les cas en
2020 avec une priorisation des violences
conjugales et ça a eu un effet puisqu'on
avec moins de féministes et des
réactivité extrêmement importante des
forces de l'ordre maintenant on est
aussi aujourd'hui ici aussi dans une
augmentation de violences graves et on
voit bien que la période de séparation
est donc actuellement beaucoup de femmes
cherchent à partir on en a aussi cette
augmentation des féminicides donc est ce
que cette augmentation des violences en
espagne elle est juste lié à ce contexte
où est ce que c'est juste
voilà un élément de plus dans dans lé
recul des violences sexistes parce que
c'est vrai qu'on est quand même en
europe et en france et on y compris
comme en espagne dans un pays dans des
pays et qui ont toujours les stéréotypes
sexistes véhiculés qui sont toujours
dans cette situation de domination des
femmes par les hommes
et donc il faut rester très vigilant en
tous les cas voilà il faut regarder ça
au prisme de de la pandémie et de voir
un petit peu ce qui va se passer dans
les prochains mois c'est vrai que la
période de séparation etc c'est sortie
du domicile actuellement en bois
qu'elles sont nombreuses et ça peut
expliquer en tous les cas de
temporairement tous les cas on l'espère
en espagne cette augmentation des
féminicides et je pense qu'effectivement
la question de la prévention l essentiel
des plus jeune âge et dans les laits
campagne de communication pour faire
aussi reculé ces violences et le
repérage ça a été dit c'est important de
pouvoir aussi opérer les premières
violences et l'a d'abord une réactivité
immédiate c'est-à-dire que dès les
premières violences il faut pouvoir
avoir une réponse policière et n'allait
pouvoir proposer aux femmes aussi d'être
accompagné nous on voit dans notre
réseau une augmentation aussi des
sollicitations et ceux ci répondra à
l'ensemble
ces fonds est ce qu'il y ait encore
quelque chose à faire son plan
législatif je pose la question parce que
les auteurs du rapport diligenté après
le féminicide de mérignac propose le
site de modifier la loi afin que tout
aménagement de peine soit précédée d'une
expertise il propose aussi d'améliorer
la protection de la victime
préalablement à la libération du
conjoint violent
faut-il alors revoir les textes de loi
et je vais me tourner dans un instant
vers vous laurence garnier elisabeth
moreno vous l'avez peut-être entendu
rappelait encore hier dans l'hémicycle
du sénat qu'il y avait eu 4 aux lois en
quatre ans le 17 mai dernier la ministre
semblait d'ailleurs contre l'idée de
légiférer à nouveau écouter aujourd'hui
il ne s'agit plus d'accumuler les lois
vous savez il ya eu trois lois qui ont
été votées dans ce gouvernement pour
protéger les victimes
donc accumulé les lois si elles ne sont
pas mises en oeuvre si elles ne sont pas
exécutées ça ne sert à rien aux fins de
la loi ne suffit pas il faut maintenant
on est rentré dans un changement de
mentalité dans un changement de culture
extrêmement important laurence garni
vous êtes d'accord avec là c'est plus du
tout sur le terrain législatif que c'est
ce jour là qui failli faire des
ajustements de la loi c'est quelque
chose qui peut être regarder si
effectivement il ya des manquements
manifestes comme semblent le dire la
mission d'inspection qui a été
diligentée suite au féminicide de
mérignac mais ce sera de toute façon
dans l'ajustement moi je crois
effectivement que il faut aujourd'hui
qu'on sera capable d'appliquer les lois
qui existent l'arsenal législatif a été
considérablement développée au cours de
ces derniers mois et au cours de ces
dernières années ça fait dix ans que
cette question de la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes montent en
puissance et heureusement dans notre
pays pour qu'on puisse enfin agir et
connaître le phénomène
ce qui pour elle relevé du ressort d'une
réflexion législatives
c'est peut-être au-delà des symptômes
c'est à dire au niveau du
quand on est face à des violences
conjugales
là nous la loi l'arsenal législatif
aujourd'hui permet à condition encore
une fois qu'il soit pleinement déployer
pleinement appliqué de répondre à un
certain nombre de contexte très
difficile
je crois que aujourd'hui ce qui serait
très intéressant c'est de réfléchir
haussier et en tant que législateur je
pense que c'est notre responsabilité aux
causes de ce phénomène vous parliez
d'espagne ont parlé de ceux des
confinement qui joue sur la montée des
féminicides tout ça s'inscrit dans un
contexte vous l'avez rappelé on avec
nous une magistrate qui l'a rappelé on
peut pas sortir les symptômes des causes
et du contexte le contexte aujourd'hui
en espagne est chez nous de la même
manière c'est de déconfinement d'une
manière plus générale il ya aussi des
causes de ce phénomène des violences
faites aux femmes des violences
conjugales je discutais encore en début
de semaine avec une représentante locale
de solidarité fans moi j'aimerais qu'on
se penche sur la pornographie à laquelle
tous les jeunes même même des enfants
ont accès aujourd'hui via les réseaux
sociaux
j'aimerais qu'on se penche sur tous ces
enjeux de réseaux sociaux qui
effectivement contribuer génère une
forme d'immédiateté une forme
d'impatience c'est ce que disait cette
responsable de solidarité femmes
aujourd'hui avec nos portables on a
cette immédiateté un l'humain n'est pas
un téléphone portable on peut pas
attendre d'humains qui répondra à vos
moindres désirs comme si comme quand
vous tapotez sur une application et
cette impatience cette immédiateté
il faut aussi s'y attaquer il faut aussi
faire en sorte que les jeunes
générations sachent se construire et je
pense que l'enjeu aujourd'hui il est
davantage sur véritablement sur les
causes on voit on sait qu'il ya un
glissement dans les violences conjugales
de plus en plus de jeunes femmes
déposent des mains courantes porte
plainte on sait que le public qui est
touchée plus en plus jeunes il ya sans
doute des causes et il faut aussi qu'on
recherche ce traitement des causes et
pas uniquement des symptômes les
avalanches oui je partage tout à fait
ces propos et je pense qu'il faut que
nous travaillons vraiment sur les causes
mais il ya aussi un
if kim kim un nom oui d'accord c'est
vraiment un tout petit chiffre évocateur
c'est qu'en fait vous avez à peu près un
auteur sur trois deux un auteur de
domicile conjugal fans féminicide sur
trois qui se suicide après les faits
voilà et je trouve que ce chiffre
interpelle aussi parce que certainement
que cet homme là il a acheminé avant de
avant d'arriver à cet acte fatal
voilà et pour avoir présidé des cours
d'assises et donc avoir jugé un certain
nombre de féminicide j'ai vu des crimes
se commettre 120 passages à l'acte
physique préalablement mais avec des
années de violence psychologique est
certainement aussi de grand malaise dans
la tête de l'assassin
voilà donc les causes sont la hausse dit
voilà c'est ça et donc là je pense aussi
que tous doivent tout cela doit nous
interpeller
de même aussi que va le climat actuel et
on voit bien quand même qu'il ya une
exacerbation de la violence
et puis on a parlé tout à l'heure dans
aparté avec le maître royaux ce
phénomène un peu de dover qu'ils
adhèrent qu ils tuent mais il ne se
satisfait pas de tuer il va achever il
va massacrer la victime
et ça c'est d'une violence vraiment
enfin je veux dire un trimestre table
inacceptable et ça doit aussi nous
interroger et à dire que nous constatons
l'horreur mais interrogeons-nous aussi
sur cette horreur ce et royaux oui c'est
vrai on est toutes et tous d'accord pour
dire qu'il faut interroger les causes et
donc apporter une réponse qui soit
globale et éducative sociale et pas
uniquement dans la répression ne pas
arriver trop tard en fait quand la
justice intervient c'est qu'on arrive un
peu tard aussi donc ça c'est vrai et
vous avez raison aussi je pense qu'il
faut définir les violences conjugales
contrairement à ce qu'on pense et pas
uniquement des violences physiques face
à dire que c'est ce qu'on voit
immédiatement mais avant la violence
physique à des violences psychologiques
un climat qui se met en place
violences psychologiques violences
sexuelles violences économiques
violences parentales et ça il faut que
les policiers les gendarmes puissent
aussi les identifier les victimes ne
sont pas toujours capables non plus donc
ça ça veut dire que encore une fois
qu'on prend le phénomène contre lequel
on lutte est il envisagé dans son dans
son ensemble et pas uniquement par par
un parent biais est encore une fois
enfin moi je insiste sur le budget
pardon là ça fait plusieurs années qu'on
demande entre 500 millions et 1 milliard
à l'eau et à la lutte contre les
violences sexuelles et sexistes pour
pouvoir d'abord avoir une réponse
judiciaire et policière des moyens
humains on l'a dit des moyens financiers
la formation et puis aussi un suivi pour
les victimes d hébergement décent une
mise en place d'un voilà d'un suivi
d'une prise en charge psychologique
auteur victime d'ailleurs et ce n'est
toujours pas le cas donc c'est vraiment
une question de l'argent on dit c'est
une priorité du quinquennat mais il faut
que ça suive et essai et ça fait
effectivement quatre ans que l'égalité
femmes-hommes a été érigée en grande
cause nationale du quinquennat à un an
de la présidentielle peut-être que c'est
déjà un tout petit peu l'heure du bilan
salé en tout cas pour la sénatrice
esther benbassa qui interpellait
justement hier la ministre c'était lors
des questions au gouvernement écouter
cent quarante six femmes tuées par leur
compagnon ou ex conjoint 2010 901 en
2020 et 49 cette année jusqu'au 5 juin
il est urgent de donner plus de moyens
d'effectifs permanents supplémentaires à
la justice de sensibiliser la police
pour agir plus efficacement de loger les
femmes victimes de violences les
relations femmes-hommes l'éducation
aller
alité l'engagement contre le patriarcat
mérite toute notre attention toute votre
attention
françoise brié est ce que vous diriez
que le bilan si tant est qu'on puisse
parler bilan alors qu'il reste encore un
an mais dans ce quinquennat alors que ça
a été une grande cause du quinquennat
vous diriez que ce bilan est mitigé ou
pas je pense qu'il ya eu des avancées
législatives en particulier il ya eu des
suites du grenelle des rencontres aussi
institutionnels ça a été ça a déjà été
dit est effectivement une mobilisation
je dirais transversale maintenant la
question des moyens on sait était saoul
il reste on a besoin d'eux de renforcer
cette chaîne de deux pôles spécialisés
on avoue souhaiter des tribunaux
spécialisés
si c'est pas possible évidemment on est
au moins des pôles spécialisés au civil
et au pénal
et comme des brigades vraiment qu'ils
soient là 24 heures sur 24
voir recevoir les femmes avec des
professionnels non seulement former mais
aussi expérimentée parce que l'analyse
du danger à vis pas il faut du temps il
faut de l'expertisé c'est vrai que une
femme si elle arrête dans un
commissariat dont un service de police
la nuit le week-end il faut aussi
qu'elles puissent être reçus par des
policiers qui soit vraiment très bien
formés référent et puis je pense qu'il
faut aussi il ya eu des avancées sur les
questions de d'exercice de l'autorité
parentale de de droit de visite et
d'hébergement mais nous on souhaiterait
aussi aller plus loin on voit bien que
les violences post séparation elles sont
très exacerbée à travers la question des
enfants et c'est aussi tout un champ
d'intervention sur lequel il va falloir
encore approfondir et est avancé par
exemple sur nous on estime que les
violences conjugales c'est un motif
grave suspendre complètement et le droit
de visite d'hébergement et l'autorité
parentale au moins a tant donné que les
femmes puissent dissimuler leur adresse
par exemple surtout dans les situations
danger donc on voit on a encore des
améliorations non sens qu'il y a il ya
eu effectivement à la suite du grenelle
des avancées et mais il faut encore
aller plus loin et surtout la question
des moyens les centres ati sûr on ne
peut pas avancer si on n'a pas
effectivement tout ce que j'ai mentionné
auparavant et toute cette chaîne
qui doit être absolument renforcer alors
elisabeth moreno l'a défendu son bilan
hier dans l'hémicycle
laurence garnier vous l'avez peut-être
entendu elle effectivement revenus sur
le grenelle des violences conjugales
4500 personnes mobilisées plus de dix
ministres at elle dit quatre fois en
quatre ans + 60 % du nombre de places
d'hébergement pour accueillir les
victimes un budget du ministère en
hausse de 40 % at-elle dit le bilan est
il si mauvais que cela laurence garnier
bon je crois qu'il faut être lucide où
on ne pourra pas empêcher tous les
féminicides en france ni ailleurs
personne n'a la recette miracle on voit
bien que les uns et les autres nous
cherchons à avancer ensemble sur cette
question je crois malgré tout qu'une
application ambitieuse des lois déjà
votées fait défaut aujourd'hui donc les
lois sont là la volonté d'avancer et là
maintenant il faut déployer une manière
concrète effectives ces lois l'exemple
de mme erignac pour lequel j'avais
interrogé le gouvernement il ya trois
semaines montrent que qu'on n'en est pas
là malheureusement tant que donnons nous
les moyens rapidement d'appliquer ce qui
existe et puis je crois aussi qu'il ya
un enjeu qui est fondamental qui est pas
d'ailleurs celui qui coûte le plus
d'argent même si bien sûr ils en
demandent aussi c'est celui de la
formation la formation de nos forces de
l'ordre il ya des progrès qui ont été
faits mais on sait qu'il ya encore
beaucoup parce qu'hier la formation je
pense aux élus les élus locaux les
maires sont confrontés aussi à ces
situations de violence conjugale
beaucoup de femmes désemparées s'adresse
aux élus pour demander un logement faire
en sorte de se sortir de l'enfer
qu'elles sont en train de vivre et je
constate que mes collègues et lui me
disent à quel point ils sont démunis
aujourd'hui pour répondre à ces
situations moi-même suite à la question
au gouvernement que j'ai posée il ya une
trois semaines j'ai reçu des messages de
femmes qui me disait dans cette
situation là et je me suis retrouvé à
happy
le 39 19 pour leur demander conseil donc
c'est pour vous dire à quel point les
élus locaux sont eux-mêmes démunis pour
pour faire face et pour apporter des
réponses à ces situations là donc je
crois que ça peut aussi être une piste à
creuser pour faire en sorte que les ceux
qui sont souvent les premiers
interlocuteurs encore une fois sans
stoller des élus locaux de ces femmes là
puisse puisse être en mesure d'orienter
ces personnes zoé royaux isabelle
rendent pour conclure oui la formation
bien sûr les services de police des
magistrats et puis la société aussi fait
encore une fois c'est une réponse
sociale et éducative des avocats aussi
une formation globale mais je pense que
il faut être lucide c'est vrai vous avez
raison on pourra pas on n'aura pas le
risque zéro malheureusement faut être
humble aussi par rapport aux chiffres
qui parlent quand même on a des lois on
a des outils faut les mettre en oeuvre
donc il faut une volonté humaine on nous
dit qu'elle est la formidable
donc ça veut dire qu'ils font une faute
des moyens financiers et pour conclure
isabelle rome oui deux formations bien
sûr un vraiment innervé tout le
territoire toutes les professions assis
sur voilà en tant que représentant du
ministère de la justice magistrate je
dirai tout de même que les choses
avancent mais évidemment avec beaucoup
d'humilité
chaque gramme nous interpelle
profondément un voile à chaque visage
qui nous est renvoyée nous renvoie
j'allais dira à nos insuffisances et je
pense que ça il faut aussi en avoir
conscience
après nous ne tombons pas dans le
défaitisme parce que voilà un curieux
nous travaillons tous les jours et de
gens se mobilisent tous les joueurs
énormément de tout coeur avec toutes
leurs forces et ça voilà je souhaite
aussi le dire parce qu'il ya un vrai
engagement et des actions aussi en
profondeur qui s'emmenait et
sensibiliser sur le sujet avec des
émissions comme celle là merci à tout
ceux d'y avoir participé
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à ce
débat c'est donc la fin de cette
émission se retrouvent le lundi à 18
heures et à 22 heures demain 7h30
bonjour chez vous au rayonnement de
chimie recevra notamment clémentine
autain peut-être
liszt la france insoumise aux régionales
en île de france et député de seine
saint denis schultz est une excellente
soirée